[Musique]
pour parler d'une tragédie qui a laissé
un trou béant temps dans les coeurs que
dans la ville le réalisateur éric morin
a filmé son abitibi natale
j'ai cru que je vais très très fictif
qui est un accident mais qui pourrait
être un drame commun en fait peu de
temps après yeux mais quand tu sais que
j'ai été très troublé par ce pays touché
en même temps j'ai vu à quel point
c'était à la fois de dévastateur pour
une communauté mais rassembleur
[Musique]
nous sommes gold est un film musical qui
met en scène le personnage de marianne
joué par monia chokri elle revient dans
son patelin dix ans après la mort de ses
parents dans une catastrophe minière
elle renoue avec son ancien groupe rock
qui s'appelle gold
beaucoup d'amis musiciens j'ai un passé
de ban ce que j'avais toujours la petite
voix si un de ses amis l'homme me dis
moi mon film pire il ya encore un peu
cheap sur la musique rock s'arrêter
maman pour assurer que le film soit
crédible et b a composé paroles et
musiques
ami de longue date du réalisateur avec
qui la fait de la musique dans les
années 90 philippe b a reçu une commande
très précis on était dans un style plus
sombre plus froides comme genève et
jeunes de kyo qui sont des groupes
viennent de milieux industriel anglais
de petites villes un peu grise qui
veulent faire du beau mais certains des
acteurs choisis ne sont ni chanteur ni
musicien était important d'avoir ce soit
la vraie voix pour qu'elles sont ils
croient pour les boursiers déjoue les
instruments sont plus faciles un peu de
de l'autriche et le tournage en abitibi
a été mémorable
il ya un plaisir fou qui je trouve
correspond exactement aux plaisirs des
personnages et nous sommes god est un
film brillant où s'entremêlent vérité et
musicalité un bel alliage ici julie
jasmin boudreau radio canada montréal
ont pour l'instant il s'est rendu